it is brett anderson the left-hander for
milwaukee who will be without christian
yelich for the series the brewery's
placing him on the injured list
colin moran who homered in last night's
game is going to be the batter
one ball and one strike one on with two
down
anderson deals again and colin moran
sends one to the shallow right
they'll throw him out
james peterson
with kesten hira covering
pirates get nothing a bank [ __ ] and
leave one stranded and right header
trevor cahill
going for the bucks tonight well
hopefully
it can do as well as brubacher did last
night
amazing garcia is the better
the one
broken bat little flare falling fast
down base hit
jackie bradley jr will score
and the brewers score first tonight as
alvi garcia
hits them where they ain't
and it's an rbi single
kind of reaches out on a breaking pitch
from cahill
it was up a little bit look at that bat
splinters right down the middle and an
rbi single
sometimes the weak contact goes for hits
billy mckinney is going to be the batter
glad to see this guy getting a start
tonight
no balls and a strike on mckinney
pulls that one that's fair just inside
the bag hits the side wall garcia will
score
narvaez to third it's an rbi single for
billy mckinney
two to nothing brewers
and mckinney able to keep that bat in
his own long enough
just inside that first base bag and down
marine
oh good start for the crew
luis orios
is going to be the batter
luis urias 143 batter
with a home run
facing trevor cahill 22 pitches here in
the first
two outs in the first here's a 3-1
and that ball's hit hard left center
that's
center field now mckinney's going to be
wound up and sent home he'll score
two more runs are in
urrius in the second on the bobble in
center four nothing brewers
that was a good send by jason lane
3-1 pitch fastball
got it down on the trademark a little
bit
let's see if they give him two rbis or
it's going to be an rbi an error
i don't think they said mckinney if
there's not a bobble out in center field
i agree
two outs runner at second peterson
on the ground up the middle through base
hit
urias will score
and it's an rbi single for jayce
peterson what an inning a five spot
and still only two outs
these baseballs have eyes right i mean
had about a four hopper up the middle
not a bad pitch i mean it was down at
two seamer
it gets through into the outfield and
aureus
unable to play run number five here in
the first inning wow
casting hero bounced out his first time
pirate infield is up
that will tent well right center field
and the run is alford it is at the base
of the wall
in the score easily is bradley
it's an rbi double for casting hero
and the brewers add one more rock six
nothing yeah you gotta wonder how long
the pirates are gonna stick with cahill
he is getting hit hard now
hira at third
six nothing milwaukee
avi sahil garcia started the first of
five consecutive two out singles in that
first inning
infield will come up and in the shift
the third baseman gonzalez though
playing back
another broken back
coming in to make the play is reynolds
here is going to tag
and here it will score
two broken bats
two rbis for avi garcia expensive night
for the brewers
this bets run about 50 bucks a piece
good thing garcia didn't have to pay for
him
seven nothing still got the bat handle
and phillip evans will be the hitter one
two pitch
and he's down on strikes a swing and a
miss now stallings hits with a runner at
third
and less than two outs
is it easier to hit a fly ball on a
pitch in or a pitch away or does it
doesn't matter
um it's easier to hit a fly ball if
you're trying to hit the ball the other
direction ground ball to short and
thrown wildly stalling's gonna be safe
and then he
tackles uh hira because hira
was still in the baseline and stallings
just can't stop immediately
and stallings did the right thing by uh
moving into foul territory there
here is luis oreos
arvayas after getting hit with a pitch
in the knee the catcher standing at
second base and mckinney at first and
the comebacker
right to second base second one relay
two double play inning over smart to let
that one go by yeah
went right between his legs on purpose
two outs
and back to the top of the order for
kevin newman
3-1
swinging a fly ball right center deep
jackie bradley jr is there and makes the
catch just onto the warning track
inning over seven strong
from brett anderson time to stretch in
milwaukee's 7-1 brewers
stallings to that has reached on an air
bounced out and lined the sutter
the pitch swinging and a rocket hit on
the ground
to
[Applause]
yardley and that does it
and defo will bat again
deep flat out to right back of the
seventh
7-1 milwaukee leads
it's number 20 for rasmussen
and he got him that's a ball game
the brewers win they beat the pirates
got some early offense a five run first
brad anderson was excellent tonight
seven strong innings no earned runs
and two relievers took it the rest of
the way as the brewers
even up this series at a game of peace
with a 7-1 victory tonight boy i love
the way the brewers came out and laid a
five spot on the pirates in the first
inning and then brett anderson did the
rest
good to see the offense come alive but
the brewers will win tomorrow
and they take the series